cam Thomas is an absolute bucket in the
NBA right now but even though he's only
22 years old he's been doing this for a
minute I'm not even talking College
let's go all the way back to high school
ever heard of oakill Academy it's a
famous High School in Virginia known for
its basketball Talent it's alumni
include guys like Carmelo KD Brandon
Jennings and more so with dozens of
former players who ended up making the
NBA guess who the school's all-time
leading scorer is that would be cam
Thomas but here's the amazing part cam
scored
2,219 points at oakill but he was only
at oakill for two seasons Thomas
transferred to o' kill as a junior
averaging 26.2 points his first season
and leading his team to a 31 and5 record
Thomas followed that up by averaging
31.5 points his senior year and leading
his team to a Tournament of Champions
title Thomas's historic senior season
included 930 plus performances in two
40o performances